all right so uh conan this is very
exciting the fine folks at sega have
come to us
and they wanted to get you uh sona
and gourley your take on their new game
fantasy star online 2 new genesis first
of all the title is way too long
do you know what i mean do you have to
say all of that or what are the kids
calling it
new gen new gen 2 what do you i mean you
could call it like pso2
colon ngs i guess if you want um always
good to work
colon into your title uh
sonia you're cool what do people call
this do you think do they use that whole
title
yeah i'd say so especially uh the colon
part okay so new genesis
fantasy star online two
colon new beginnings the resurrection
is that something like that yeah okay i
think i just fixed the title
so fantasy star online two new genesis
it's an upcoming i know i'm so sorry so
long you got it
it's an online action rpg game with a
sci-fi anime setting it's the latest in
the fantasy star game series and the
successor to fantasy star online 2.
wow okay i was going to uh stop you and
ask what rpg is but i won't
because that would have uh meant that
you repeated the title
and then i'd have a long great beard so
fantasy star on line two new genesis
is set a thousand years after the events
of fantasy star online two
and the battle of oracle and so fantasy
star online two new justices takes place
on
alpha a planet in which arcs who the
soldiers of the oracle colony fleet in
the fantasy star on line two series
are locked in a battle for dominance
against the mysterious d-o-l-l-s
dolls i thought we could just show maybe
uh you know uh you
sona and gourley uh kind of the opening
cinematic here and you guys can kind of
you know kind of give us your thoughts
as we're watching it if that's okay
i like these parts the best cause i
don't do anything
at any point is there a frog that tries
to dodge traffic
i don't want to spoil anything
[Laughter]
now but a game okay no here we go
we see a well it seems like a a hawk
a white hawk with a long tail wow that's
in
harfa avian yeah
a man standing on a rock oh it's a woman
you can't tell these days with the long
hair on the rock and roll
uh birds and those are pokemon robots
and pokemons live together i like her
hair
i think those are the mysterious dolls
the dolls
so oh so that is a guy yeah that's our
hero
right and he's wearing some kind of
armor
kind of an iron man storm sort of thing
yeah
and he's got a lightsaber well i'm sure
they have a different name for it than
lightsaber that would be litigious
yeah they have weapons and they can use
the photon arts which are kind of using
cosmic energies they're focusing cosmic
energy we all know what
photon arts are right yeah okay this is
a battle that's happening and it looks
like they're defeating
oh he just ran his he ran his sword
right through the doll
and it blew up that's cool yeah he got
don't you defeat one giant robot oh
there's there's always another one
oh my god look at this guy he's like a
shogun warrior
do you remember those yeah another old
reference here we go
you know that had a um anime kind of
animation which i found uh
kind of groovy and it looked like it was
good action
what do you guys think what stuck out
for me when i watched it uh
was my new crush actually i would say he
was in the mech suit
he did a super sick backflip off that
cliff
you're like oh the guy in the beginning
yeah the suit was
the coolest thing for me so you're
saying that your ideal
guy right now is someone wearing that
suit who can do a back flip off some
rocks
is that what you're saying nailed it
okay i get it what's cool about this
game is you can really
change your avatar you can pick every
little different
aspect to make it look exactly how you
want things like
you could change your hair color your
eye size the size of your hands
your thigh thickness yes i want thick
thighs
i want i want needle thin thighs i've
never had
thick thighs and i want them yeah hands
thick thighs yes i want tiny hands and
just
just massive sausagey thighs
i'm just realizing that i had the
original sega master system i chose that
over nintendo and they had a fantastic
fantasy star game for that was the first
one i think did you play it wow
i don't remember if i played that but i
used to play my sega all the time
there we go did you have uh you had
friends right no no not a one
this is early on what year are we
talking about here mid to late 80s i
think i can't remember what year yeah
but i loved it that's cool so you were
an original fan and now you can return
with this much better version of the
game
everyone in this game kind of has these
robot suits what about in real life
if you guys could have a robot suit what
would you want
as part of in your robot soup i would
just want a lot of
snacks yeah i would pretty much do like
a candy dish
yes i would want like oh this you know
there's candy here there's hard candies
here
there's sort of uh candies with a shell
yeah but like an eminem or a peanut m
m over here there's like a starburst
over in this section and then there's um
like a soda fountain yeah and a straw
you would have just like a mechanized
version of bib overalls
yeah exactly coralie what would you have
in your neck suit
would you have in your robot suit hmm i
guess
you know i think i would loot strings i
knew
a spare vintage dime novel for you to
read
ironically i would just have uh earmuffs
so i wouldn't have to hear this abuse
we would all die so fast i think as a
team you guys would crush it we would
get crushed we would kill each other
no three people work worse together
doing anything
i know just talking the three of us it
doesn't go well
it often leads to whiplash and harsh
feelings all around
we are rock scissors paper personified
yeah
if you guys were going to team up to
fight a giant
enemy what would your strategy be what's
your battle strategy going in
sacrifice conan yeah instantly yeah i
think
uh yeah sona and matt would pick me up
and throw me
at the giant uh robot
um and then they would keep giving me
new life so they could throw me into
something else
he's got all the snacks yeah so just be
like a pinata
yeah exactly i would explain you're
right sonja is right i would explode
and uh doritos and starbursts would fly
everywhere and the robots would just be
delightfully
eating the orange broken pinata and uh
you guys would have plenty of time to
leave and
and build a house and suddenly it would
be minecraft i'm certainly into this
game i'd like to play this that would
totally be our strategy i think it'd be
good
one of the things that's very exciting
about this game is it's cross
platform so you can play if you have pc
and you have xbox one you guys could
play with each other
blai i want you to have an operation
where we remove the jargon from you
because when you start saying this is
cross platform you can play with an rpg
and a flip-flop and a chip chop i don't
know if i'm coming or going if it's
north south east or west you know this
game as
you guys probably have already guessed
has new multi-weapon
systems and abilities where you can
combine two types of weapons for
smooth smoother weapon switching you
know i don't understand what you're
doing oh god
you can take a a spear and and combine
it with a machine gun and then it's a
spear machine gun is that what you mean
let's say you've just respawned in this
role-playing game and you need to
swap out your phaser blaster with let's
say a photon ionizer
it's just that simple see it's that easy
so it's cool you can you're constantly
upgrading
it's the problem with the american dream
constantly not satisfied what we have
well yeah i mean you can you know you
can make your player better and better
and better i mean the other thing i
wanted to say is um
i have a question have they ever thought
about making a game
uh called zen where you don't get any
better
but you accept yourself for what you are
oh
wow you don't level up because you're
already there it sounds real boring
is there cross platform the numbers are
in for example
is there a colon between the z and the e
yes okay
z e colon n so to
wrap up what do you guys think would you
play this together what do you guys
think about that i think it'd be good
for us
a good team building exercise because
matt sona and i
we need to get more in sync we we work
together
we a lot of people listen to us and
there's a lot of squabbling there's a
lot of budding of heads
a lot of people not listening to who's
clearly the alpha male
oh i think what we should do listen to
me a lot i don't know
i don't know i i think it couldn't hurt
us to play this game maybe get together
sona we could all get together at your
house and play this game i mean i think
the point is you could all we could all
be at our own house oh i forgot of how
computers work
i thought that we were all going to play
you know
uh some board game together like trouble
and or hungry hungry hippos i had to
drive over to your house and gorilla's
going to drive over and we're going to
have dip and chips yeah and then play
together
i forgot the very essence of this
technology
yeah i mean you can still i don't want
to go over there
well so fantasy star uh online two new
genesis
uh it comes out pc it comes out on pc
and xbox one in june i think you guys
will play it maybe this will help we're
gonna play it we're gonna
and you know what we are gonna get
together and play at the same room are
we i'm gonna rent us a nice hotel room
we're all gonna go there and we're gonna
order up
some lobster okay and uh yeah
and some champagne we're gonna play
together it's fancy beautiful
yeah sounds excessive i'm gonna use uh
someone else's credit card
you